hello and welcome to another exclusive
collider Sundance interview
brought to you by Kia Telluride huge
thanks to them for making this happen
because it means we get to share with
you cool Sundance movies like the wolf
hour thank you so much to the three of
you for being here
Alistair I wanted to start with you
first it's been a little while since
your last film so I was wondering if you
could paint a picture of the journey
from that one to what we get in the wolf
hour I mean funny enough the film kind
of chronicles a little bit of my journey
in a in a loose loosely based way but
you know I was not not working that the
whole time I think I was just really not
finding the right project to land and
then I had a few projects that you know
didn't quite make it and you know next
thing you know it's been a little
sometimes it's just meant to be fall
into place as it does a lot of people
out there do not know what the wolf hour
is about yet so I will leave it to
whoever would like to do it does anybody
want to give a brief synopsis of the
movie the wolf hour follows a character
Jun Jun Lee who is a recluse living on
the top floor of her tenement building
in the South Bronx in 1977 and it's
clearly a bit off the grid and
struggling to just get the basic
necessities of her life life going and
one morning someone starts ringing her
Bell incessantly and she doesn't seem to
be able to go down to see who it is it's
a it's a creepy touch to it I feel like
anybody could sit there in picture their
apartment alarm going off like that the
buzzer going off and it just keeps you
awake at night there's also this feeling
that you know even when the movie takes
place compared to now in modern times
really the darkness around us can kind
of consume us and make us a little
reclusive and stuck in ourselves so I
was wondering is there anything that the
three of you turned to to kind of get
through tougher times just as a source
of inspiration for anybody watching this
really for me I was looking at I mean I
think and everyone has experienced a
level of depression or anxiety over
certain periods of their lives this was
obviously a very heightened version of
that and she's built a really good case
for why it works for her not to go out
and interact with the rest of the world
apart from the fact that the killer you
know this this Sam aspect Son of Sam
there's many other things she's done
damage to her family structure and and
doesn't want to damage any more people
and herself included so yeah I just did
research on depression I don't have that
reclusive thing on my depression
manifests in different ways when I
experienced it I kind of want to escape
and like rely on and connect with other
people but I can relate to that loss of
relevance that feeling of you know where
you're filled with self-doubt and
self-loathing and your art is no longer
relevant and you and you know but you
have to keep creating and how do you
keep doing that when you're getting
blocked over and over again I think
that's something that's really human for
anyone who isn't a tough spot out there
hopefully they have a character like
yours to turn to who will at least step
in and try to help so is there anyone in
your life that you turn to when you kind
of need someone to give you a little
boost yes my my husband my mother my my
children my puppy not necessarily in
that order but yes absolutely I feel
very I feel very fortunate but yes
people I think when people can become
isolated and it can become so hard to
break through
and and leave the loneliness there's
only one thing that could take me away
from talking about movies and it's
bringing up a puppy but I'm gonna
control myself right now I want to ask a
little bit about the casting process
because obviously you've surrounded
yourself with a great ensemble here and
I was curious for the lead role in
particular how exactly does that happen
do you make a list and put Naomi's name
at the very top of it and keep your
fingers crossed
yeah I mean Naomi's in the top most
people's list I would assume but the
yeah I got really lucky that she
connected with the script and and
invited me to have coffee with her and
we just had a really magical afternoon
talking about the character and where it
was headed and it just felt like the
most natural thing for me and and
hopefully for her too and you know we
just set off down the path it's as
simple as that you have a very very
extensive career with a lot of different
kinds of films and because we're at
Sundance right now a festival that can
really make a difference for certain
artists and really kind of change the
industry I just wanted to get your sense
of how you choose projects especially
when we're talking about some smaller
movies that need to make waves at a
festival versus a big studio blockbuster
project yeah it's never that calculated
I just I mean I think for the most part
I'm looking for a character that's gonna
move me and it's gonna teach me
something in my own spiritual growth in
some way it just lifts off the page and
sometimes it can be just a scene that
makes you go wow this this is the whole
part and this is why I have to do it
sometimes it becomes clearer later and I
think we're just always looking for
growth as an artist to try new things
and you know it depends what you've done
previously and
you know it makes makes a good argument
for trying something the opposite of
what you've just experienced is there a
piece of this character you're going to
take with you I like to let them go to
be honest some sometimes actually
physical things and and and the accent
and they're hard things to break
actually because you study the accent so
much and and American accents are not my
comfort zone at all so when you study
and you change your vowel shapes and
things like that and walk the way the
way you walk and hold your body yeah
those are the things you have to really
shake off so from this project to a
really really big project a little
something called Game of Thrones we have
many viewers out there who are huge huge
fans so was there kind of that
connective element to the character
you're going to play there that really
drew you to that I can't really talk
about the character all I can say is
that the show the brand that everything
that Game of Thrones sets out to achieve
it does in such a terrific way and it's
just a great group of people to be
involved with it is a whole new group of
people that said it's very connected
obviously to the same author and and I'm
just super thrilled it isn't a blind
trust in the brand or do you get all the
information I got all and I I'm not
gonna go I'm not gonna get myself in
trouble oh no sir of course yes it's a
very exciting thing to have coming up
and so is this as well so I will remind
you all the wolf hour keep an eye out
for it a huge congratulations to you all
thank you for being here another thank
you for Kia Telluride for making all of
this happen like and share this
interview we will see you soon with more
Sundance coverage
you